anger and shock
outside a salt hospital in amman a
one-hour cut of vital oxygen supplies
has been blamed on the deaths of
patients
it affected intensive care maternity and
coronavirus wards
a backup supply arrived too late for
some
ana my father and mother are at the
coronavirus isolation zone inside the
hospital
by coincidence i was inside the hospital
when suddenly the oxygen was cut
we asked off who said they had run out
of oxygen and that they are waiting for
a truck for more supplies
we received assistance from the civil
defense some of them were inside the
hospital
and they provided oxygen cylinders and
then started to resuscitate patients
among them my parents security forces
have been called in
preventing anyone unauthorized from
entering the hospital
these people have no choice but to wait
for news
there was an oxygen outage and there
were no measures to prevent this
it is known that in all jordanian
hospitals there are motors available
just in case electricity goes down
even before the coronavirus outbreak
when there are surgeries at hospitals
there's always spare equipment but here
there was an oxygen outage
i gave my father cpr three times and
twice to my mother
i called the director of the hospital at
10 30. the isolation ward has only one
doctor and two nurses to serve 50 to 60
patients
this is unfair
the fallout was swift health minister
nathir obaid resigned
and king abdullah arrived to a mixed
reception from crowds at the hospital
he immediately ordered the hospital's
director to also resign
parliament has set up a special
committee to investigate
and prime minister bashar al-assad says
there is no justification for what
happened
the government and only the government
takes full responsibility for this very
painful incident
we will not resort to excuses or
justifications about what happened
what happened was horrific so it is
impossible to deny
or to escape responsibility the death of
one jordanian due to these failings
is unacceptable but there are people
here who say the hospital was
understaffed and ill-prepared and many
are asking why a failure like this
went unnoticed until it was too late
laura burden manly al jazeera